hier drin ist ja der Big Mac der
wahrscheinlich bekannt ist für Burger
der Welt nicht umsonst gibt es den Big
Mac Index um anzuzeigen wie viel
Kaufkraft ein Land hat es gibt in den
über 119 Ländern dieser Welt und wir
machen heute nach zumindest versuchen
wir es weil ich glaube das kann leichter
Job allein diese Tüte in der Hand zu
haben zu riechen was ich rieche ist
einfach schon so original aber um die
nachzumachen müssen wir erstmal gucken
was eigentlich drauf ist er wiegt
relativ leicht in meiner Hand und der
Big Mac ist eigentlich nicht so big also
wir müssen jetzt kein Mutanten Burger
zaubern heute charakteristisch natürlich
dieses Mittelband also das ist nicht nur
die zwei oben unten gibt sondern das
mittlere dann hier sehen wir schon die
Big Mac Soße kennt man liebt man
vielleicht ich persönlich mag sie sehr
sehr gerne also einfach der Decke wie
gesagt nichts drunter natürlich schön
angepostet wichtig ein wirklich mini
Patty wenn ich ehrlich bin dann ein zwei
Gewürzgurken ein bisschen Eisbergsalat
und Big Mac Soße ganz wichtig dann haben
wir wieder ein Patty mit Käse
darunter Eisbergsalat Big Mac Soße
fertig klingt wie eine ganz leichte
Aufgabe aber wir wollen alles selbst
machen wir wollen ihn komplett nachbauen
und am Ende auch diesen typischen
Geschmack herauskitzeln deshalb legen
wir los und womit macht man das
natürlich mit dem Bann los geht's und
als allererstes stellen wir einen
Quellstück her das nennt man auch
tangeng Song ist aus der japanischen
Küche und ist so viel wie keine Ahnung
so ein kleiner Gummiball der das gleich
viel fluffiger macht ihr werdet sehen
das Rezept für die Burger buns habe ich
von Joshua weiß man weiß man hat auch
ein paar better mit Big Mac gemacht das
verlinke ich euch mal könnt ihr euch
gerne anschauen wir wollen aber gar
nicht so wie er unbedingt einen besseren
Big Mac machen sondern wir wollen einen
machen der so ist wie ein Big Mac ob er
dann besser schmeckt durch die Zutaten
dadurch dass wir alles fresh machen wir
werden sehen aber das ist der Anspruch
für heute 15 Gramm Mehl in einen Topf
darunter rühren wir 120 ml Milch und 100
ml Wasser ist das Mehl komplett
aufgenommen ist und wenn das der Fall
ist machen wir unseren Herd auf
mittlerer Hitze an rühren währenddessen
die ganze Zeit weiter bis die
Flüssigkeit ein bisschen rausgekocht ist
und dann werdet ihr erkennen wird das
Ganze so einer dicken Masse beguckt euch
das an man merkt schon das ganze wird
bisschen dickflüssiger und ab jetzt geht
es richtig schnell fleißig rühren es
soll auch nicht zu heiß werden ich
gesichert habe bisschen runter dann
nehmen wir das von der Hitze geben das
in einen Schälchen und lassen es
abkühlen so ich habe jetzt ein bisschen
Milch und Wasser warm werden lassen
einfach lauwarm nicht zu warm ganz
wichtig denn wir werden gleich mit Hefe
arbeiten wir schnapp uns jetzt ein Mesh
besser
einen Messbecher das waren die 120 ml
Wasser zu viel und 100 ml Wasser
120 ml Wasser und genauso viel Milch
rühren darin jetzt Zucker unter 30 Gramm
Margarita Technik wenn Margarita gelernt
wenn beides verbunden ist noch ein
kleiner temperaturcheck geben wir
instant Hefe dazu und auch das kurz
stehen lassen damit die Hefe aktiviert
wird wir haben unser Quellstück unsere
Hilfe Mischung jetzt brauchen wir noch
Mehl das geben wir in eine Rührschüssel
und noch ein bisschen Salz dazu bekommen
ein bisschen nach oben hast keine Ahnung
so ein bisschen verquirlen das ganze und
jetzt zunächst einmal die Flüssigkeit
hinzugeben als nächstes das Quellstück
relativ flüssig dann ein Ei und ein
Eigelb in euer Teig ungefähr so aussieht
könnt ihr nach und nach ein bisschen
weiche Butter hinzugeben etwa 3
Esslöffel also schon ein bisschen was so
sieht das Ganze aus wenn es gut
verknetet ist der Teig hat so einen
richtigen Widerstand und sollte nicht an
den Fingern kleben sehr gut ich habe
schon geölte Schale vorbereitet sondern
Formen wir eine Kugel und geben ihn in
seine Schüssel darin decken wir jetzt
mit Frischhaltefolie ab und lassen ihn
für eine Stunde ruhen bis er sich
verdoppelt hat in seiner Größe ungefähr
eine Stunde später ist unser Teig
ordentlich in der Größe gewachsen wir
haben noch mal den Ofen gestellt weil es
hier nicht so warm ist einfach und
ich sag mal so ich bin kein Bäcker bin
zufrieden und jetzt jetzt müssen wir ihn
niederschmettern bis er seine ganze Luft
hier mühevoll aufgebaut hat wieder
verliert so red so und jetzt müssen wir
ihn in Achtel unterteilen je nachdem wie
groß man halt die Bands haben möchte ne
kann man auch zehn machen ja wir wollen
ja relativ klein haben daraus formen
jetzt kleine Thai Kügelchen und jetzt
stecken wir das mit einem weiteren
Backblech von oben ab und lassen die
Nummer für 20 Minuten ruhen schaut euch
an was ich schönes für die Soße
vorbereitet habt fein gewürfelte
Gemüsezwiebeln fein gewürfelte
Gewürzgurke Senf Ketchup Mario
Zwiebelpulver alles zusammenwerfen und
gut vermengt fangen wir an als erstes
geben wir die Mario rein und boom boom
boom boom ich glaube auch hier kann man
ein bisschen mit augenmaße Arbeiten
bisschen mehr Mario gleiche Anteil
Ketchup und Senf ich habe einfach Mittel
scharfen genommen es gibt auch diesen
super knallgeld ich glaube der ist noch
besser Gewürzgurken Zwiebeln frisch
gemahlenes Zwiebelpulver
okay Pfeffer Salz eine geriebene
Knoblauchzehe so das muss reichen
zack gehen wir dazu so geriebener
Knoblauch knallt auch wirklich viel viel
mehr ne ja das ist auch eine ältere Zehe
die schon gekeimt hat deshalb vorsichtig
besser damit eine Zutat fehlt noch
entweder ein bisschen Weißweinessig oder
aber einfach Gurkenwasser kennt man auch
keinen krasser Geheimtipp aber ist
wichtig alles zu einer Soße verwenden
erinnert doch schon mal stark eine Big
Mac Soße das kann eins zu eins aber ich
glaube für Big Mac Soße brauchen wir
noch ein bisschen Zucker einfach noch
eine Prise Zucker dazu
industriesachen ist Zucker drin da
wollen wir heute hin
also schon fast so besorgniserregend nah
dran boah steck meinen Finger rein ich
bin sowas von bereit ich bin auch bereit
gucken wir sie uns an unsere Burger
Bands sehen jetzt so aus bisschen
aufgegangen das Gute ist da passiert
noch einiges im Ofen jetzt bepinseln wir
die erstmal mit einem Ei und ein
bisschen Wasser verkühlt genauso machen
wir das bei allen anderen und dann
kommen sie bei 190 Grad für 17 Minuten
bzw bis die goldbraun sind in den Ofen
unseren Eisbergsalat können wir in der
Zwischenzeit schon mal ganz fein
schneiden fein und hart
ne ohne Mandoline das hat schon so
Meckes Ausmaß wenn ich so diese super
dünnen Eisberg Dinger ich glaube da
stehen sie auch in der Küche und
schneiden den morgens probier mal den
Eisbergsalat ob der auch schmeckt 1A ja
ja eine gewisse Süße das kann sich sehen
sehr sehr schön geworden mein Favorit
ist vorne links hier haben wir
Rindfleisch und es kommt jetzt darauf an
die perfekte Größe für die Patties zu
finden ich habe hier einen setzring der
ziemlich perfekt um den Burger passt für
das zweimal perfekt gesagt aber es hat
mich auch sehr glücklich gemacht zu
sehen wie gut das passt das heißt wir
nehmen uns jetzt ein bisschen Backpapier
beim Big Mac ich habe das geschmeckt
kommt auf jeden Fall auch zu großen Teil
so auf diesen Brot Salat Soßen Geschmack
an nicht nur auf den Fleischgeschmack
der eigentlich natürlich bei einem
Burger im Vordergrund steht oder
vielleicht sogar stehen sollte ne Formen
das jetzt richtig dünn aus machen kein
Smash Pad die kann nichts mit der Burger
Presse wird auf jeden Fall ein bisschen
schneller gehen schatz du darfst auf
jeden Fall ja aber das sieht super aus
ne hat noch ein bisschen dieses
natürlich jetzt ein bisschen Profil hat
aber ist auch nicht unbedingt schlecht
würde ich sagen schnappen wir uns unser
Baby und jetzt brauchen wir chirurgische
Präzision wir wollen wirklich eine
schöne Unterseite schneiden den
Mittelteil aus dem ganzen Band weil
unser Band ist so schön hoch dass wir
uns das erlauben können und wir wollen
ihn am Ende ja noch vernünftig essen
können boah es sieht gut aus ja
eingebaute Wasserwaage so haben wir
normales McDonald's
aussieht können wir sie sehen wann sind
getoastet Zeit für unsere Patties wir
legen sie auf die glühend heiße Plancha
pro Seite ein bisschen anbraten scharf
anbraten dürfen sie mit Salz und wir
flippen
hat wirklich viel von so einem Fast Food
Patty oder ja aber im McDonald's Style
müssen die auf jeden Fall ganz
durchgebraten man merkt auch hier dass
die Kruste nicht überall ist weil man
ist nicht drauf gedrückt hat ja ne ja
also wirklich nur die Auflagefläche ist
jetzt richtig geworden okay schauen wir
uns mal an auf der Unterseite starten
wir auf jeden Fall mit ein bisschen Big
Mac Soße fein geschnittene Eisbergsalat
auch nicht zu viel eine Scheibe Käse und
lassen niemand ein bisschen mit
anschnelzen das legen wir dann falsch
rum drauf und zack so schmilzt die
Käsescheibe verbeugt sich ein bisschen
nach unten ein guter Plan jetzt kommt
das mittlere Band einfach oben drauf
wieder ein wenig von der Big mac-soße
wieder ein bisschen Salat lassen sich
auch so viel Zeit beim Meckes
1 2 3 Gewürzgurken drauf das nächste
Patty so Deckel drauf und
da ist das Ding und jetzt guckt sie euch
mal nebeneinander an
[Musik]
guckt euch das an worüber würde man sich
mehr freuen das hier ist der altbekannte
Anblick und das hier ist die selfmade
Version das sieht irgendwie ein bisschen
mehr nach der Werbung für einen Big Mac
aus ist aber ein richtiger Apparat also
der ist wesentlich schwerer auch test
test würde ich sagen oder ich habe
richtig Bock da rein zu beißen
die Ähnlichkeit ist schon also das ist
wirklich so wie dieser hübsche schöne
Bruder
darf man das überhaupt vergleichen darf
man einen selbstgemachten mit Liebe
zubereiteten Burger mit einem
industriell gefertigten
Schnellrestaurant Burger vergleichen das
Ding ist ein Big Mac schmeckt nicht so
sehr nach Burger also nach einem Burger
aus einem normalen Restaurant nach einem
Burger die man selbst macht der schmeckt
nicht so sehr nach Burger das fällt mir
gerade richtig auf ne ich esse den und
der schmeckt einfach nicht so sehr nach
Burger sondern der schmeckt nach Big Mac
obwohl die Soße wirklich schmeckt wie
Big Mac Soße obwohl der Salat drauf ist
obwohl der Käse drauf ist schmeckt nach
einem Burger also das ist so wir haben
auch das Fleisch extra dünn gemacht hat
sich halt sehr zusammengezogen so es hat
trotzdem einfach ein viel kräftigeren
Burger Geschmack so also das ist auf
jeden Fall das bessere
Geschmackserlebnis aber das ist halt ein
Big Mac auf jeden Fall ein spannendes
Experiment mein Ansatz war ja nicht ist
besser zu machen sondern es nachzumachen
und der ist nicht so wirklich gelungen
also irgendwie kann man dieses Produkt
wirklich einfach so nachmachen
vielleicht ist auch gut so weil
vielleicht will ich gar nicht wissen was
Big Mac zu Big Mac macht ich hoffe es
hat euch trotzdem gefallen habt ihr eine
Idee mit welchen Produkt ich das als
nächstes ausprobieren soll was ist ein
Klassiker den ihr gerne mal selbst
gemacht sehen würdet schreibt es in die
Kommentare bis zum nächsten Mal hier
kannst du Kanal abonnieren hier ist ein
für dich vorgeschlagenes Video nur für
dich deshalb guckst bitte an hat
wirklich der Algorithmus für dich
ausgewählt bis dahin ciao ciao ciao